你想吧，
某种程度上啊，
只要你愿意给他俩摁，
他都说不承认他的转账，
我可以是打牌呀，
我可以是输了钱呀，
我可以是一起出去旅游AA呀，
是吧，
一起做什么项目啊，
一起做生意呀，
他不会承认的，
即便是你今天给他摁到了，
他说刚开始他勾引我的，
我是在1号的时候呢，
发现老公出车2+1的这个事情，
而且不是一个固定对象，
发现那天真的是一种鬼首神差的感觉，
我拿他手机抖音，
恢复了聊天记录，
他真的是吓了一大跳，
我觉得这肯定是完全都看不下去了吧，
我们的情况在一起8年，
结婚7年，
有个男孩儿，
今年的话是在一起第9个年头了，
我们是在二线城市，
刚结婚的时后呢是有房有车的，
房车的话呢，
都是他婚前买的，
我是婚后生完孩子之后呢，
没人帮衬，
所以一个人是全职带娃的一个情况，
我的家庭情况的话呢，
也会比较复杂一点，
我是单亲家庭，
妈妈的话呢，
也帮衬不了，
期间生孩子过后呢，
我妈是过来帮我带了一年的孩子，
所以的话期间也上了一年的班，
后面的话呢，
也就回归了家庭，
又继续带娃生活了，
到生孩子，
到目前的这个情况的话呢，
我们结婚的那。
的时间是从这个公司辞职了之后呢，
和朋友创业到目前为止，
那么多年以来，
其实都没有做起来过，
然后亏了很多的钱，
所以现在我们的负债情况其实是很严重的，
车子也在这个期间呢，
变卖，
然后拿去还债了，
房子的话，
其实那个抵押贷款和现在我们这边的房价的话，
基本上它是持平的，
所以相当于我们名下是并没有任何资产的一个情况，
而且还有负债的，
他大概负债会有100多个，
我的话呢是有五十几个这样子，
包括利息在里面，
我的负债一个情况来源，
主要是因为这几年负债情况比较严重嘛，
他在平台上贷不了钱之后，
他就和我商量的情况下，
让我去借贷，
然后呢，
当时也想两个人竟然都结婚了嘛，
应该真诚相待，
在困难的时候能一起面对，
相互扶持，
这一点再也没什么，
日子都会好起来的，
我对他的感情其实是很深厚的，
刚开始在一起的时候，
他是领导层嘛，
然后我对他是对他的个人努力和他的这个魅力来吸引的，
对他就是那种很崇拜的感觉，
所以即使这几年来负债那么严重的情况下，
我也会无条件的去信任和支持他。
但生完孩子那几年的。
啊，
我都是属于那种对他单方面付出，
他对于我的话就好像没有太多感情的那种，
但是经过这几年的相处，
好像就是孩子也长大了嘛，
他对我和孩子的话感觉还不错，
是有在意感，
对家庭呢也是有需要的。
在盛发之前，
我可能都还会有一种错觉，
就是觉得自己好像很幸福很幸运一样，
平出一下我的心情，
因为之前呢，
就是一直强忍着，
就没碰，
不过也没长不清楚，
然后一下突然绷不住了，
很正常，
谁遇到这种事儿都会有一种信任坍塌，
都会有觉得不真实，
然后心里开始否认这个阶段。
但还是那句话，
就直播间的姐妹，
你应该知道龙飞姐姐心里想的是啥，
就你老公出你自己得癌症你选哪一个？
你老公出和孩子得病无治之症，
你选哪一个？
你老公出是吧，
和他卷着你所有的钱都跑了，
你选哪一个？
你这么一算起来，
老公出是最便宜的，
这无伤大雅的，
没有什么攻击力的，
这没有什么伤害性的，
那我为什么还是经过就这么两天的时间，
我就只这那么快，
其实也是有原因的，
因为在结婚之前哈，
其实发现他是那种玩家，
但是我想着嘛，
两个人结婚之后，
天生的以为对方可能也会像我一样回归家庭，
既然你有了家庭和孩子，
那可能是你不想玩了，
也玩了那么久了，
但是呢，
还是我太天真了，
在。
这期间发现他在聊天软件上有聊解的那种情况嘛，
发现了这个情况之后，
我确实也很难过，
但是又觉得好像一切都是在意料之中一样，
我发现他不止一个2+1的这种情况是什么呢？
他其实在这个过程当中，
包括到现在哈，
他都是和人保持这种像陆水情人一样断断续续的，
不是一个固定的绿场，
但是其中在目前为止，
我发现三个人的话呢，
有一个人是确定已经不联系了的，
但是那个人也是最可恨的，
因为当时我结婚之后怀孕呢，
他们是在做公司，
这个女的话是他公司的一个员工，
我不知道具体是什么职位，
这个女的在我生孩子期间还在一定院来看过我，
在家里做月子期间，
她在家里照顾我的情绪，
然后呢，
给我的孩子买尿布，
他还说可以当我的娘家人，
反正就是搞得好像真的是很关心我一样，
现在他来就是天，
这人好，
实物是那种，
我没有抓到他们的实锤，
这个女的也是有家庭有两个孩子的，
我就想问，
如果说我有这些转账记录，
哪些钱是可以追溯回来的，
追溯期是有多久？
因为现在我是处于严重负债的情况，
我是没有办法去起诉的，
到时候如果说我要和他摊牌的情况下，
因为现在我还要利用。
妈妈，
我要让他赚钱，
所以我把这个债给还了，
我和孩子还需要他当成工，
所以现在不是最佳的时机，
我给你讲一个技巧好不好，
这个技巧叫什么呢？
从我发现我老公给第三者转账之日起，
我三年之内起诉都行，
听明白了，
你啥时候想起诉，
你知道我刚发现，
但是那个账单的话，
下载出来不是有记录吗？
账单你又不是说今天能下载，
明天就不能下载了，
因为我好像是什么5年那些，
所以我就是怕的是这种情况，
你说我把他账单发到我这上面的一个时间记录，
我就是怕这个东西没有人会追究这个，
真到那个什么的时候，
法官也是睁一只眼闭一只眼，
没有人追究你什么时候发到自己邮箱的，
没有人追究你是什么时候知道的，
那因为之前我也去搜过，
我就是怕过了这个追溯期的话，
我就难了，
因为现在确实没有钱去打这个官司，
从发现之日起开始算3年之内是吧，
比如说我想跟他打官司了，
我就拉出来这5年的转账记录啊，
就这意思就是法官会以我自己说什么时候发现的时间为主，
比如说我明天要去打官司，
我今天拉一个转账记录出来，
拉5年的转账记录出来，
是不是我就是我刚发现，
我昨儿刚发现，
那我就知道了，
我能有足够的时间去盘算，
就一自己打算啊，
我是以我的名义还是。
说让你老公去把这个钱给追回来呢，
只能以你的名义，
你老公还要不回来呢，
如你老公想要他还要不回来，
只能以你的名义，
能要回来好的，
然后他的公司其实是有一些大大小小的转账的，
就比如说除了这两个520之外，
也会有高额转账，
哪些账是追的回来，
哪些账追不回来，
这个怎么算呢？
只要对方解释不清楚，
一个已婚的男人为什么给他转账，
你就大概率讲能追的回来好的，
因为他们是有来由回的，
但是账好像是弄不清楚的那种，
我还有第二的问题，
就不过我要摊牌的话，
那么我在没有做到现场的这些情况下，
我拿着这些证据去找他谈判，
那么我怕他不承认，
所以说我要不要真的做到现场之后再去谈并把握，
还是说这些证据是足够的呢？
我跟你想吧，
某种程度上啊，
只要你每意给他俩摁上，
他都说不承认他的转账，
我可以是打牌呀，
我可以是输了钱呀，
我可以是一起出去旅游AA呀，
是吧，
一起做什么项目啊，
一起做生意啊，
他不会承认的，
即便是你今天给他摁那了，
他说刚开始他勾引我的，
好的，
我应该怎么做才能抓到他那的现场的，
其实我你想过那种什么真踪器之类的，
不知道合不合法，
在你自己的车里装什么都合法，
在你自己的房间里面装什么。
合法，
他一般都会在外面，
从来没有带过来，
家人谨慎，
在外面开花都是拿现金的那种，
那你只能跟着他了，
所以这个取证真的还是有点难度的，
你想买。
第3个问题，
王萍姐，
如果说我继续跟他相处的话，
那么我是在保护好自己的情况下，
说实话还有夫妻生活的，
他是什么都还没有发现，
但是我也不确定哈，
但如果说我还要装，
到时机成熟的情况下，
我要怎么样和他去演戏，
因为我情绪想到这个的话，
我还是有一点点反复的，
你要不想跟他，
你就说你得病了，
什么HPV啊，
就这个那的，
要分床才能治好，
知道吧。
最后一个问题，
我找他摊牌的话，
我就把所谓的这些什么离婚协议，
夫妻财产约定书全部的东西全部准备好，
跟他摊牌，
那么如果说他在承认的情况下呢，
我们就可以签夫妻财产约定书，
不承认的情况下签离婚协议，
如果说他两者都不想做的情况下，
那么我就用所有的证据，
应该是有利于我，
足够保证我的利益的吧？
你这话问的我不知道该怎么回答，
因为我就是怕打官司的时候自己会输，
所以我想说还需要哪些证据才能足够去保证我和孩子的利益？
我跟你说，
两口子之间的官司啊，
谈不上输和赢，
什么叫赢，
什么叫输呢？
你想。
要什么，
你得到了就赢，
比如说我只想要孩子，
我不要钱，
我得到了孩子我就赢了，
比如说我只想要出气，
我不要钱，
我孩子都不要好，
我出了气我就赢了，
真的两口子打官司了，
输和赢他就是看你心里想要什么，
渴望什么，
想得到什么好的。
我看到了评论区很多姐妹说，
为啥负债了我还要这样子，
因为现在的话，
我是处于一个没有能力去挣钱，
然后带孩子的一个阶段，
我还要靠着他去给我和孩子当长工，
现在他不好并不代表他几年之后不好，
所以我还想着就是在我能力还是强的情况下，
我想让他先去保证一下我们的生活，
然后挣钱，
看能不能这几年之后把我的债给平了，
然后在我们有资产的情况下，
我再去给他摊牌，
是这样子的，
好的，
那咱俩就聊到这里啊，
好，
谢谢龙小姐，
拜拜，
就是我们女人啊，
如果自己没有能力还钱的那个额度啊，
千万不要感情用事，
什么你哥让你去借钱，
你哥让你去贷款，
你弟弟让你去刷信用卡，
你老公让你去签什么协议啊这那的啊，
让你去透支自己的信用啊，
你先掂量一下自己能不能还得起，
你要说自己还不起的话，
你任何人都不值得信任，
其实也不是说他们不想还你，
因为你做生意也好，
就做什么不。
账户也好，
他可能也不是不想还你，
他也没本事还你，
没错吧，
所以你们就得自己没有本事还这个钱的时候，
千万不要去签那些透支啊贷款啊，
给别人去搞什么信用卡呀，
别搞这个啊，
答应我好吗？
不然的话，
原本是亲人到最后都会成为仇人。
记得点赞关注哦。